welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar exploring the
link between infection and mental
illness results from nationwide studies
presented by Olay Koehler forth with RIT
University in Copenhagen University
Hospital Denmark Massachusetts General
Hospital and Harvard University
my name is Alexis Corrales and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Lavery's
leopards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before you begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want but any time you
want during the presentation since I
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
we're hearing the presentation please
click on ask a question box to let us
know that you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtaining credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Olea Kohler forsberg I
will now turn the presentation over to
him yes hi everyone and thank you for
joining I was a thank you for inviting
me to give a speech at this at the
conference and as it was introduced I I
kind of talked about the link between
infections and mental illness and gonna
present some of our studies based on a
Danish nationwide registers so what I
want to tell you about today is first of
all I want to shortly introduce you kind
of two to the concept of Denmark as a
country for register based research and
all the possibilities and that we have
in Denmark and then as I mentioned
presents some of the studies we
performed
on infections and the subsequent risk
for mental disorders and then finally I
want to shortly discuss some of the
potential mechanisms and that may
explain some of our findings but before
we come to that I will just shortly
present kind of the concept of the
inflammatory hypothesis in Mensa Tesoro
suggests that everyone is on the same
page so inflammation sa concept has been
associated with many different diseases
and disorders but just to mention some
are cancer or cardiovascular diseases of
course but during the recent decades
more and more evidence has pointed
towards that inflammation also is
important in diety etiology of mental
disorders and just to mention some
examples from studies in in
schizophrenia here's one meats analysis
from Michael Burke groups in Australia
where they found that c-reactive protein
is increased in patients with
schizophrenia compared to healthy
controls and c-reactive protein is as
you of course know is one of the most
important blood markers to measure the
inflammatory load and also some other
studies where they investigated in soy
beans 6 which is one of the most
important and cytokines in in the body
which also was found increased in
patients with schizophrenia and also the
same for interleukin 1 which has also
been found an increase and these were
just some examples for schizophrenia the
the results are quite similar for for
some depression bipolar a lot of mental
disorders so there is there is cried
robust evidence that that inflammation
the immune system is you know increased
are associated with mental disorders and
some studies have also investigated
whether this link between the immune
system and mental illness could be due
to genetic factors and just to mention
one short example kind of a very well
known paper in nature for a couple of
years ago
you know you see on this Manhattan plot
you see on the x-axis all the
chromosomes and the largest Association
and this genome-wide Association study
on schizophrenia was in the major histor
history compatibility complex gene so
which is one of the most important parts
of the immune system so all the genetic
links point towards an association
between mental disorders or in this case
schizophrenia and the immune system but
after this short introduction I will now
explain the concept of the the Danish
versus based research so Denmark is a
nice little beautiful country in the
northern part of Europe and it sits
there by approximately 5.5 million
inhabitants and what makes it so good
and exclusive for register-based
research is that there is this CPR
number register so every Danish citizen
and either at birth or when you
immigrate to to Denmark and everybody
receives a personal number a personal
number and with that number what most of
a lot of X things are our registered for
example just to mention a few things
which which I will also you know use in
this presentation and Hospital contacts
are registered so for example in Denmark
all psychiatric hospital contacts have
been registered since 1969 and all
contacts to the somatic hospitals have
been registered since 1977 so this is
really a huge database with a database
with a lot of follow-up and in addition
there is a the prescription database so
since 1995 and all prescriptions that
were redeemed at Danish pharmacies they
have been they have been registered so
as you can see this is kind of a very
broad and good a setting and in addition
to these specific registers that I
mentioned there are a lot of other
registers for education
whether one is in work and and so on so
that is also possible to include
important information on them and
specific confounders for these studies
but this is kind of the overall setting
for for the Danish register based
studies and now I'll first present you
know not so the studies on the actual
infections and mental disorders and I
will first present a study from a good
colleague of mine Michael Ben Rose where
they investigated and the association
between autoimmune diseases and severe
infections as risk factors for
schizophrenia so they followed a total
of 3.5 million things throughout 1977
until 2006 and there they had 39,000
cases of patients with schizophrenia and
this figure shows it quite quite nicely
that you see on the x-axis and there are
shown the amount of Hospital contacts
with infections so in this study they
they only had access to hospital contact
so it's only the severe infections but
as you can see the risk for
schizophrenia increases depending on the
amount of Hospital contacts with severe
infections and further this figure also
shows the difference between the red and
the blue bars that those who in addition
also had an Elgin disease events assess
any kind of algae immune disease those
had were associated with an even higher
risk for developing schizophrenia and
clear dose-response relationship between
the amount of severe infections and a
higher risk for schizophrenia
furthermore they also looked into the
specific types of infections and this is
this one a slightly different study but
still the same data and where they found
that that you know Hospital contacts for
infections in general increased the risk
for schizophrenia but then when they
looked on the specific agent that that
cost
the infection they found that bacterial
infections increased the risk the most
and even more than viral infections or
other type of infections our way you
know and these are very interesting a
good study but but kind of the
limitation the major limitation was that
in this study they only included the
severe infections so they only had
information on Hospital contacts with
infections which of course are the most
severe whereas the majority of
infections in the population our of
course not causing a hospitalization but
they are treated by the general
practitioner so to approach these
limitations we wanted to perform some
studies where we included information on
the less severe infections and those are
some of the studies that I want to
present to you now and what we did is
that we as I mentioned earlier in
Denmark there are and there's this
prescription registry with all routine
prescriptions since 1995 so we have
information on all the routine
prescriptions for all anti-infective
agents since 1995 and that included
antibiotics antivirals and my colleagues
and NZ prosthetic agents and again this
this is
outpatient treatments so when when a
patient for example went to the general
practitioner and the general
practitioner you know made a
prescription for and financed the
infective agent and the patient redeemed
it so we have no information on
treatment during hospital stays and the
first study that I would like to present
you is a study on childhood and
adolescence mental disorders so it was
it was recently published and here we
investigated the association between the
treated infections and the subsequent
risk of mental disorders and children
and adolescents and as you can see here
it's just shortly shown from the
abstract we included all individuals
born between 1995
and 2012 which yielded a study
population of almost 1.1 million
individuals and as a show dimension the
exposure was that we could include all
the treated infections so we included
both an information under severe
infections that required a hospital
contact and which also was the main
exposure in the study which I've shown
before but here we also had the
information on the less severe
infections that were treated with the
anti-infective agents in a primary care
setting and the results showed that
first if I present the findings on on
the severe infections so they've
Hospital contacts with infections here
we found that individuals who had been
hospitalized with an infections compared
to individuals without hospital contacts
they were associated with an 84 percent
increased risk for any mental disorder
diagnosis so this means a risk for being
diagnosed with a mental disorder na and
in a hospital but it was also associated
with an increased risk for just any
psychotropic medication use so when when
individuals redeemed a prescription for
antidepressants or antipsychotics or
ADHD medication so this was the severe
infections to the hospitalizations and
when we then included this additional
information on the less severe
infections that were treated with
anti-infective agents we found that
these less severe infections were
associated with a 40% increased risk for
being diagnosed with a mental disorder
in a hospital based setting and a 22
percent increased for redeeming a
psychotropic medication so also this
this kind of quite nicely shows that
infections in general the severe
infections but also the less severe
infections are associated with an
increased risk for meds of the source
and these analyses were associated for
for civil important confounders such as
mental disorders and the parents or the
educational level of the parents next I
would like to show you these figures
where this is this figure is showing the
risk for a being diagnosed with a mental
disorder in a hospital setting and on
the x-axis you have the amount of
anti-infective agents so all the
different times that these individuals
are redeemed a prescription for a
infective agents and you can see again
that the risk increases in a dose
response relationship and that the risk
was higher among those who also had been
hospitalized for an infection which is
the light blue bars and we found the
same dose response association for for
for the risk for prescriptions for
psychotropic medication and so showing
that that the risk for both mental
disorder and hospital setting but also
psychotropic medication increased
depending on BM actions and also the
severe insistence it was higher among
those who were also hospitalized with an
infection okay and now I will show a bit
Alissa's a bit busy table but this is
just to give you an overview of what we
did in this study so the results that I
presented on so now were on just mental
disorders in general but then we also
look on the specific disorders that were
diagnosed in the hospital based setting
and when we looked on this specific
disorder or the specific mental disorder
categories we found that the highest
risk M were associated with the
schizophrenia spectrum disorders anxiety
disorders specifically OCD there were
also four personality and behavior
disorders mental retardation which are
now is now called cognitive impairment
but MD ICD whu-oh system it's called
mental retardation and we also found
increased risk for the entire spectrum
of behavioral at
not disorders so this more the second
view on the specific disorders highlight
some specifics and some specific
disorder disorder categories and then
that were more increased than others
okay so this was a study done on the
infections and then childhood and
adolescence mental disorders and as a
next time I study I want to show you a
study where we investigated specifically
on affective and schizophrenia spectrum
disorders and this in this study which
which was published a couple of years
ago and here we included approximately 1
million things that were born between
1985 and 2002 and we had follow up until
2 2013 so you can see that this is an
early onset of affective and the
schizophrenia spectrum disorders but as
in the previous study we had information
on on the Redeem prescriptions for
Atlanta infective agents and also on
hospice or contacts for infections so
it's a bit a bit the same set up and the
same exposures but just that we had a
bit older started study population and
longer follow-up we and what we found is
that when we investigated the risk for
the less severe infections that were
treated with anti-infective agents we
found that we found an increased risk of
64% for being diagnosed with an
affective disorder and we also found a
37% increased risk for being diagnosed
with a schizophrenia spectrum disorder
and these risks were even higher among
those individuals who also had been
hospitalized with an infection so the
risk also increased depending on the
severity of the infection and
furthermore as you can see in this
figure we also found that those response
relations so again the x-axis you can
see the amount of anti-infective agents
that
redeems and you can see that the blue
bars are the risks for affective
disorders whereas the red bars are is
other risk for for schizophrenia
spectrum disorders and for both outcomes
we found a dose-response relationship
which was a bit more pronounced for the
affective disorders as a next step we
then looked on the specific
anti-infective agents as you can see
here so specifically the antibiotics
antivirals and semiotics and
antiparasitics and for the antibiotics
we divided the antibiotics depending on
the broad spectrum or narrow spectrum of
these drugs and and these numbers shown
here are the risk for developing is it's
a Fenian spectrum disorder and as you
can see the risks were higher for
antibiotics and we found no significant
findings for for antivirals and see my
colleagues and anti parasites
furthermore the interesting part is that
and the risk was higher depending on the
more broad spectrum of the antibiotics
so the broad-spectrum antibiotics were
solid associated with the highest risks
whereas the narrow spectrum were
associated with a bit lower risk and we
found the same associations for
regarding the risk for affective
disorders again antibiotics and
specifically the broad-spectrum
antibiotics were associated with the
highest risks for affective disorders so
then overall we found that that
infections or the treatment without care
of the the antibiotics were associated
with an increased risk of these severe
mental disorders and we both found that
for childhood at Allison's mental
disorders and and the severe mental
disorders affective schizophrenia
spectrum disorders and these findings
can be explained by by several factors
so first of all the infection itself can
of course even if it's a peripheral
infection these infections
are known that there also can affect the
brain and the central nervous system so
the first possibility is that the
infection itself can affect the brain
and hence leads to this increased risk
for mental disorders another possible
explanation is and as also broad whether
the infections or the antibiotics
another possible explanation is that the
treatment itself can affect the gut
microbiome and and through that way
affect the brain so a lot of research
during the recent years has pointed
towards the importance of the gut
microbiome and brain access and and it
is known that that antibiotic
specifically affect the microbiome and
since there are many rules of
communication between the gut the
microbiome and the brain this is one
possibility although this is still a lot
of research has been has has to be
performed in this area to further
understand this potential link and next
explanation and explanation is as also
shortly mentioned in the introduction is
genetics so our findings could be
explained by that that these individuals
are just at a kind of genetically higher
risk for acquiring infections and being
diagnosed with immense of this order so
since there have been findings between
genes coding for the immune system and
mental disorders this could be explained
by genetic factors but in addition to
these three potential mechanisms and one
additional and very important
explanation is is due to the nature of
our studies so our own our studies are
our observational nature and hence it is
very important to think of the
socioeconomic status so the
socioeconomic status could explain
several of our findings and which
basically means that that the lower
socioeconomic status then the less
education the less hygiene
lower socioeconomic status is also
associated with a higher risk for mental
disorders and that this lower
socioeconomic status also could lead to
more infections so they kind of the
associations we have found could be
explained by these socioeconomic status
and aspects but overall a lot of
possible explanations but in general
some interesting findings linking
infections and immune system with mental
disorders and who this I would like to
thank you very much for your attention
thank you thank you dr. Cole we're
forsberg for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
labyrinth for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this podcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June 2019 as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you submitted via email that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we will see you next time goodbye